feier laune bei den deutschen olympia
sportlern in crank skispringer andreas
bellinger freute sich über die am
samstag erflogen eine goldmedaille
schnell habe er gewusst dass das ein
guter sprung war so weninger während der
pressekonferenz zum sieg gestern zweiter
durchgang habe ich direkt nach dem
absprung merkte ich bin deutlich höher
und weiß es geht weit war überzeugt von
von mir dass ich es kann genauso dass
ich da unten den telemark mache ohne mit
der wimper zu zucken und ja das ist
glaube ich auch eine stärke die ich mir
die letzten monate arbeitet habe dass
ich eben auch im hohen weiten bereich
gute haltungsnoten kriegen kann
stolze 113,5 meter hatte der 22-jährige
wellinger zurückgelegt was ihm 259,3
punkte einbrachte die norweger vor
fangen und johansson verwies er auf
silber und bronze ebenfalls am samstag
hatte bereits biathletin laura dahlmeier
gold geholt sie gewann den sprint über
7,5 kilometer mit einem vorsprung von 24
2 sekunden
gemeinsam mit wellinger ließ sich die 24
jährige am samstag im deutschen haus in
pyongyang feiern